I'm showing people are imagining
um lawyers a young black woman for white
cane isn't what you know their first
picture would be
but
um
hopefully I'm able to change that type
of imagery the famous wig and gown given
even more symbolism
by qualifying as Britain's first blind
black female Barrister Jessica anaba has
shattered a triple glazed glass ceiling
unable to see since birth
she decided she wanted to be a lawyer at
the age of 18.
but during law school she lacked study
material in Braille the tactile system
she uses to read
so listen to how she decided to make
some with the help of her younger
brother I'll tell him to read some
either headings
and when we find the specific heading
that I'm looking for he would read to me
and I would type out
she beat the odds at University but
statistics show her journey will
continue to be difficult according to a
study by the bar Council a black woman
who is a publicly funded criminal Junior
Barrister would bill on average 18 700
pound a year less than a white male
counterpart in England the Wales last
year there are only five black British
female King's councils a position that
recognizes legal excellence
while only one percent of Judges were
black in the year since those findings a
follow-up report found nine in ten
Chambers have committed to doing more I
think it's important to remember that
barristers provide legal representation
for all of us
um and so it's it's hugely important
that barristers reflect the diversity of
our own Society because I think that
means that people have much more
confidence in the justice system Jess
knows all about the power of that
representation it helped her build bonds
with clients during her Masters
especially when I have a black clients
African clients and Caribbean clients
they they say to me you know we we're
really proud to see you a young black
woman with a disability in this position
her Focus now are pupilage to gain some
on-the-job experience and training
having done so much already she has
disadvise for anyone facing adversity if
you want to become a barrister you want
to become anything else but you feel
like
um
society says that your disability or
your race or your gender means that you
cannot achieve what you want to achieve
prove them wrong
that ambition and that approach
something we can all learn from
Sky News